emmy-winning actress christine baranski
has had a three decade career the
Juilliard train stars dozens of credits
on stage and on screen bronski's best
known for portraying lawyer Diane
Lockhart on the CBS drama The Good Wife
she brought back the role for the
spin-off series the good fight it was
the first scripted series from CBS all
access
that's a subscription streaming service
on Sunday season two premiere there's a
season two of the good fight
Diane considers taking a new position
from someone who has betrayed her in the
past this is a preview I've been asked
to be a partner at another firm twice
the size of Riddick Bozeman and you're
wondering if I should go the offer came
from someone who betrayed me well
someone who betrayed you once will
betray you again that's a given good but
isn't it better to go with the devil
that you know I never understood that
expression why not go with no Devils I
just don't like hustling every day to
keep this firm afloat yes you do you
love it
Christine Baranski welcome back to the
table I love that scene where she says
why not go with no Devils which I
absolutely agree with but the thing
about this show that I think is so great
is that you guys really push the
envelope you talk about white supremacy
referring to the President of the United
States you talk about racial injustice
you talk about sexual harassment it
really pushes the envelope is that what
you like about it well I don't see how
if you're doing a show with characters
that are living in this in our surreal
time how you cannot address what is you
know a world off its access and so it
addresses exactly the world that the
real time and they're lawyers so there
that is their reality they have to do
cases on sexual harassment and and white
supremacy or gun violence or so I think
more than ever I've been playing this
character for nine years and I've never
had more fun it's never been more rock
and roll in terms of the writing this
character of Diane Lockhart you know
very pull together
beautiful clothes always the grown-up in
the room
elegant eloquent she gets unhinged she
watch she's addicted to Cable News she
can't believe what she's watching as you
know can you relate to this you can yeah
my process what's going on and she
doesn't know what to do anymore she
doesn't know how to cope and that takes
her to even doing some micro dosing and
having a little gun in her desk getting
very paranoid and cookie this is a wine
say yes and saying exactly what she
means and she drops the f-word and takes
off her shoes and you see a different
Dianne you see a Diane that's more like
that you know you never see Diane like
that I'm always saying to the
hairdresser make it messy is she
fighting the good fight what is the good
fight but I mean you could interpret
that so many times I think the good
fight is trying desperately to hold on
to your value system at least for this
character or how to live in the present
moment without losing your mind I would
say that's the overreaching theme of
this this particular season which is 13
episodes
yeah but even last year was a different
world as you know when I did your show
last year we were talking at a different
level of you know current events and it
was weird enough then but the
interesting thing is for the writers
they they have to chase the news in
order to stay on top of it they almost
have to anticipate what's going to
happen we just did an episode on
impeachment we just finished an episode
on the golden shower tape and by the
time I mean by pushing the author
Christopher I know well they're being
really brave this year but why shouldn't
they be we're on we're not on network we
can afford to be brave and we're living
in times that are so on eboshit and
audacious as artists as writers as
actors we have to go to that place which
is to say we don't care if we offend
people because there are obviously
people who support who are on
other sides of some of these issues who
have deep strong feelings that would be
opposed to those but we have characters
who are also pro Trump I'm into the
writers credit they don't only write one
side and I would say that they argue
that they're not writing a political
show that was never their intention to
be polemical or to lecture the audience
they're writing about characters with
strong views because they're intelligent
people working a lot in a law firm and
they're living their lives so people
have very strong these days strong I was
just gonna say to go you know from The
Good Wife to the good fight part of the
popularity has been able to see these
incredibly strong women that that women
have longed for to see on television I
know and they're women of different
colors different generations different
ages I started this show in my mid-50s
and so nine years later do the math it's
great 42 you know what I love is that
record you have a woman my age at the
head of the law firm but it's not made
an issue of it's not put in quotation
myself yeah
and it's and we're Sanger with a smart
cookie because you went to Oxford and
was staying in a dorm room cold concrete
steel I just love using another part of
my brain it's one of my regrets that I
didn't go to university I loved being a
school girl I love libraries and books
and doing homework and and this Oxford
offers a summer program and two years
ago I did TE Lawrence and and she did
very well
less wound up against the wall I got a
go Christine there's no we're cheering
you on yeah thank you so much like not a
part of the family collecting baranski
the new season of a good fight premieres
Sunday on CBS all access you can find it
at cbs.com on the CBS molap and
streaming players like Apple TV and
chromecast you can find it